la tension ne retombe pas en mer
méditerranée la marine grecque a été
mise en état d' alerte ce mercredi après
que la turquie a dépêché des navires de
guerre à proximité de l'île kastellorizo
les bateaux turcs accompagner un
bâtiment d'exploration gazière sous
marine une attitude condamnée ce jeudi
par emmanuel macron alors qu'il recevait
son homologue chypriote dans cette
partie de la méditerranée qui est vital
pour tous nos pays les questions
énergétiques et de sécurité sont
aujourd'hui essentiel qu'elles sont
l'enjeu de luttes de puissance en
particulier de la turquie et de la
russie qui s'affirme de plus en plus et
face auxquels l'union européenne pèse
encore trop peu ce serait une grave
erreur que de laisser notre sécurité en
méditerranée aux mains d'autres acteurs
cela n'est pas une option pour l'europe
est en tout cas ça n'est pas quelque
chose que la france laissera faire les
tensions entre la turquie et la france
sont montés d'un cran juin dernier un
incident maritime entre deux bâtiments
de guerre turcs et français a relancé
les dissensions
la grèce a elle assuré qu'elle était
prête à défendre ses droits souverains
contre tout type de menace
après les manoeuvres d'ankara notre
gouvernement souligne que l'annoncent
d'activités d'exploration turque dans
certaines parties du plateau continental
grecs avec des marins en situation
irrégulière constitue une escalade de la
tension dans la région
dans le même temps cela montre les
actions hostiles continuelle de la
turquie et son mépris total du droit
international de son côté la russie a
appelé au dialogue les différentes
parties impliquées dans les conflits de
cette région du globe
nous suivons attentivement et avec
inquiétude la nouvelle escalade de
tension en méditerranée orientale
nous préconisons le règlement des
divergences par la négociation sur la
base des normes universelles reconnu du
droit international et nous appelons les
différentes parties à oeuvrer pour
renforcer le retour de la confiance et
des relations de bon voisinage et aussi
à s'abstenir totalement de prendre des
mesures unilatérales
réfléchis pour résoudre efficacement les
différents qui se manifeste il existe la
plate forme universelle qui est
l'organisation des nations unies en
outre le mécanisme de délimitation des
zones économiques exclusives et du
plateau continental entre les états est
stipulé dans la convention des nations
unies sur le droit de la mer de 1982 la
france devrait accueillir un sommet de
l'alliance des pays du sud de l'union
européenne nommé med 7 pour évoquer la
situation en méditerranée orientale
l'espagne le portugal l'italie la grèce
malte et chypre y participeront à la fin
du mois d'août ou au début du mois de
septembre